[Musique]
moi ça m'a pris un peu de temps avant de
pouvoir l'envisager
enfin d'accepter que je n'aurai jamais
d'enfants moi c'est peut-être pas la
peine de le mettre dans votre rapport
un bon candidat l'adoption c'est pas
quelqu'un qui a vécu douloureux dans la
vie on a tous ses champs de mines et des
champs de fleurs
nous ce qu'on veut savoir c'est si vous
avez réussi à déminer votre chance
c'est un petit garçon voulait le voir
bonjour je suis assistante sociale
je veux pas le regarder je vous appelle
parce qu'on va sûrement avoir un petit
pupilles et accueillir probablement
demain vous seriez discours m'a proposé
de faire un accueil jory que j'ai envie
raclée qui a quel âge faire un jour
[Musique]
bonjour théo je m'appelle karine tu
éducatrices spécialisées comme tu le
sais ta maman on ne peut pas s'occuper
de toi dans l'immédiat mais elle nous a
chargés de veiller sur toi et nous on
est là pour ça pour toi continue à bien
voir tu sais un beau prendre du poids
le conseil de famille a donné ses
directives pour trouver des parents ce
petit et ou à l'islande doit sa première
demande d'agrément de 18 ans elle est
prête cette femme c'est bon moment pour
elle je le sais
[Musique]
je me sent carrément prête
tu grimpes tu grimpes du groupe
mon travail c'est pas trouvé un enfant
des parents qui souffrent
mon travail c'est de trouver les
meilleurs parents possible des enfants
en difficulté
t'inquiète pas ça va bien se passer
tu est un super mec
[Musique]